warning this site is for scp personnel
with o5 approval
access beyond this point for those with
standard level 4 security is prohibited
and may result in termination of
foundation employment
unauthorized visitors who survive the
memetic kill agent are detained and
interrogated under truth exacting
memetic agents
dr herman wright was used to high
security protocols
he had been working with the scp
foundation for several years
and had dealt with specimens both
terrifying and valuable
but something about this site was
different the security was tighter than
he'd ever seen
and it all seemed a bit too much for
what looked like a run-of-the-mill
warehouse in alexandria
egypt this street seemed normal it was
surrounded by businesses selling food
and clothes
and none of the locals seemed to give a
second glance
but as soon as he was approved for
access and entered the warehouse
it was a very different story he looked
into the cognitohazard testing screen
designed to cause psychic damage to
anyone who hadn't been inoculated by the
foundation
and entered the large bunker automated
guns lined the walls
he could see the outlines of trap doors
below him and he was pretty sure the
whole place was rigged to blow if a
large-scale assault hit
the foundation was taking no chance with
whatever they had found in egypt
what could they be keeping mocked up
below as dr wright walked through the
long tunnel leading to the staircase
he could see a series of rules marked on
the wall
no open flames allowed within scp-4001
no firearms or bladed weapons allowed
within scp-4001
all writing utensils brought into
scp-4001 must be approved by a majority
of the o5 council
violating these conditions could cause a
ck-class restructuring scenario
or an xk-class end-of-the-world scenario
dr wright's mind raced as he entered the
massive antechamber
and descended the staircase but he
wasn't prepared for what he saw
it was a library the biggest library he
had ever seen
with bookcases stretched as far as the
eye could see
the library was far bigger than the
warehouse look from the outside
and dr wright assumed it must be a
disguise built on top of the much bigger
older facility that had been discovered
by the foundation
it wouldn't be the first time the
foundation found something that didn't
conform to the laws of euclidean
geometry
scp locations often played by their own
rules
as dr wright exited the staircase and
walked up to the first bookcase
he could swear he heard rustling sounds
among the shelves
was something moving he hadn't seen
anyone walking the aisles when he
descended the staircase
and he was pretty sure he was alone here
wasn't he
making things stranger a quick look at
the bookcase didn't show any books he
was familiar with
none had standard titles in fact they
all seem to follow a simple format
each title a different individual person
all books look the exact same same
binding
same thickness same number of pages was
this some sort of scp reference library
suddenly a hand slapped down on dr
right's shoulder and his heart nearly
jumped out of his chest
he turned to see a gray-haired man in an
scp lab coat extending a hand to him
dr weyland henriks chief scientist in
charge of testing at scp-4001
you must be dr wright he didn't give dr
wright a chance to respond
dr henricks didn't seem like the kind of
man to be very interested in what others
had to say
yes yes about time the foundation sent
me a new research assistant
i suppose you have a lot of questions dr
wright was supposed to be a researcher
not an assistant he didn't suppose it
would do any good to point that out
when dr wright tried to question what it
was that he'd be researching
dr henrich told him that it would be
easier to show than
explain with that he motioned dr wright
to a nearby table
where one of the countless identical
books on the shelves was waiting
he nodded at the book prompting the
younger doctor to turn it over and read
the title
he couldn't believe what he saw there on
the front of the book was his name
herman wright dr wright looked at his
colleague in confusion
and dr henrik's motion for him to take a
look it was written in a language that
he had never seen before
but was somehow instantly recognizable
and understandable
and the book really was about him every
detail of his life had been written down
in this volume
starting with his birth containing
details that no one but he knew
his whole life story was here from his
childhood to his education to his
eventual recruitment by the scp
foundation
but the book wasn't completed the last
line that had been written described his
entry into the secured confines of
scp-4001 that very day
dr henrichs had a mad glint in his eye
are you starting to understand
one for each of us every person who has
ever lived roughly 120 billion people
since the dawn of man
their lives are written down in these
books every time someone is born their
book appears in this library
and their story gets written as it
happens the foundation has been
monitoring this site since the 1800s
but it's been operating much longer than
that since the dawn of recorded history
dr henrich's past talked to write
another book it was simply titled
the hunter and it chronicled the life of
a prehistoric man who spent his days
searching for wild game
he lived 23 violent monotonous years
before his story ended abruptly
when the saber-tooth tiger decided it
was interested in the same mammoth he
was hunting
this must have been one of the oldest
books in the library
a book for every person on earth dr i
could only imagine what the scale of
this massive library must be
dr henrich explained that mapping the
library was a huge challenge
before producing a map from his pocket
and laying it out on the desk
you're at base camp this is where new
births generate on the shelves along
with books pertaining to the first
humans
if you want to drag down specific books
you'll need to know where you're going
we've established base camps around the
library to mark significant errors in
human history with notable books
at each camp you'll find generators
supplies and beacons to light your way
if you're going back far enough you
could be traveling for days or even
weeks
dr wright was fascinated by this bizarre
location
containing the sum total of human
experience within its massively
expanding walls
but there was one thing he couldn't
figure out just why was this seemingly
harmless location featuring constantly
changing books the most securely guarded
scp
he had ever encountered dr henrich knew
he was referring to the extensive rules
he had must have seen as he entered
the other doctor reached into his pocket
and said
let's just say that around here the pan
is mightier than the sword he pressed
the pen into dr wright's hand and
flipped open the back page of his book
it was blank the rest of his story
waiting to be written
what's something you've always wanted in
your life dr wright
think literally why not put it in your
book or remove
something you've always wanted gone
slowly dr wright thought back to his
teenage
years and recalled an injury that he
suffered in a mugging that damaged his
leg and left him with a limp
he nervously used the pen to scribble
out the words and sentences describing
the event
after a few seconds he felt a headache
and suffered from a slight nosebleed
after that the limp and pain from the
injury was gone
and he could no longer recall the event
you see dr wright
that's the secret of scp-4001
dr henrik said with a mad gleam in his
eye this library doesn't just
let us read the history of humanity it
lets us write it
that's why you're here to test the limit
of this power
and see what this library can do for the
foundation
dr henrich soon provided dr wright with
footage of some of the many tests
conducted in the library
and what dr wright saw amazed him the
books could rewrite the laws of nature
with alarming speed
as some unfortunate d-class personnel
found out
d-0546 was brought into a room with a
full head of hair
the d-class personnel was instructed to
scribble lost all hair into his book
and he soon started scratching his head
as he rapidly started shedding hair
after less than two minutes the man was
completely bald
d-0567 a young woman who had been
brutally injured when attacked by an
escaping scp
was bed-ridden and would never walk
again according to all the foundation
doctors
as the d-class personnel used a pen to
scribble over the line in her book
describing her injury
dr wright watched as she suffered a
minor nosebleed and then sat up
getting out of bed as if she had never
been injured and no longer remembered
being attacked dr claire williams
a foundation researcher sick with cancer
wrote into the book about curing her
symptoms
and then addressed the camera explaining
that this was her third time altering
her own book
her lymphoma symptoms had returned after
several months and two years
respectively
but it seemed that as long as she
continued to make changes to her book
then she could keep the cancer at bay
indefinitely
but not all the tests ended with
positive results as dr wright moved on
to another selection of tapes labeled
mortality tests a d-class personnel who
was given a fatal dose of drugs and then
had their death erased from their book
45 minutes later
miraculously returned to life but showed
significant cognitive deficits after
another d-class an older woman killed in
a containment breach had her death
erased from the book
but came back deeply disturbed she
survived 15 days in containment
repeating send me back let me go
over and over again before committing
suicide
a d-class personnel killed 28 days prior
was brought back by writing
returned back to life in their book but
died again just 13 minutes later from a
cerebral hemorrhage
but it was the next tape that was the
most disturbing
it documented a new book that was
written by the foundation
depicting the life of a fictional man
down to the slightest detail
it was carefully placed in the correct
position in the archives
resembling all the other books and dr
wright watched the tape in amazement as
the man resembling the fictional
character
created for the books spontaneously
generated in scp-4001
almost immediately the man started
vomiting blood and died less than two
minutes later
the book carefully described all the
things he died from and stated that this
was exactly as it was supposed to be
the fake book then disappeared into the
archives never to be seen again
the archive knew when it was being used
to play with life and death
and it didn't want any part of it the
next tape wasn't a test at all
it was a video interview showing a greek
speaking scientist speaking with an
ancient looking old man
found living in the archives slowly
after its discovery by the foundation
the man who described himself as the
watcher of alexandria eternal
believed he was keeping the archives
safe from the roman empire and the other
invaders
he was unaware that thousands of years
had passed since his watch began
he had been using the books to write
himself another day of life
and to cure his ills ever since he began
guarding the library
at the conclusion of the interview he
asked to leave and this request was
granted by the foundation
the ancient man died of old age shortly
after setting foot
out of the library while the library
can't technically cure death
it does seem to have nearly limitless
ability to prolong life
as long as someone is willing to stay
close by and never forgets to write
themselves
another day where did this incredible
power come from
an o5 authorized investigation into the
origins of scp-4001 revealed that under
the archive's carpet
is a concrete floor covered by a layer
of ash
the ash was carbon dated to between 70
and 80 thousand years old
and further analysis revealed the ash is
likely to be the remains of burnt wood
and paper
despite there being no known records
within the archive itself about a major
fire having occurred there
dr wright didn't have much time to dwell
on the library's great power of life
because he was suddenly shaken from his
thoughts by the sound of alarms
was the library being breached no it was
foundation officials
led by a man recognized as dr lincoln
abrams
the very man who assigned him to this
project and he did not look happy
he explained that he knew what dr
weyland henricks had been up to
writing in books changing the lives of
subordinates in an attempt to play god
he knew about everything of course
because he had read dr henrik's own book
he knew all of the doctor's secrets he
knew
everything no i'm so close dr abrams
i know i can crack the archives rules
there's a way to conquer death here i
can feel it
dr abrams was done listening and with a
wave of his hand foundation security
took dr henricks into custody for a
debriefing and likely demotion
dr abrams then turned his attention to
the new young researcher
dr wright eventful first day i gather
i'll appoint a new lead scientist
shortly
but until then don't disrupt anything
remember the archive is writing our
stories as we speak
it's not very happy with dr henrik's
make sure your story turns out better
and with that dr abrams and his security
team departed
leaving dr herman wright alone with the
endless archives of alexandria eternal
wondering what would be written in his
own tone as the sound of new books
popping into existence filled the air
with ominous rustling
for more strange locations that defy the
laws of nature check out
scp-3008 trapped in ikea or check out
this video instead